on April fifteenth 2013 two bombs
exploded near the finish line at the
Boston Marathon the blast killed three
people and wounded at least 260 others
and almost two years after the ordeal
isn't quite over the trial against the
surviving suspect Dzhokhar tsarnaev has
begun but will this unpopular young man
receive a fair trial and can the US
justice system work even if you're an
alleged terrorism suspect George 02 is
the federal judge presiding over the sub
knife case O'Toole alter presided over
another high-profile terrorism trial
that of 29 year-old Bostonian tarek
mehanna mohandas crime was translating
al qaeda documents from arabic to
english and publishing them on online
forums his lawyers argued that he was
exercising his right to free speech
protected by the First Amendment despite
the case being about constitutionally
protected free speech prosecutors made
it about conspiracy and material support
and judge O'Toole's management's of the
case was criticized by members of the
legal community who say he blurred the
lines between protected political speech
and terrorism activities so we're gonna
see I think another round of the
presiding judge conducting the trial
that seems fair but in fact may not be
fair towards the defendant I'm afraid
that power fix will get mixed up with
charges of violence and that will push
the jury toward not only a conviction
but I fear toward a death sentence and
that brings us to the jury in Djakarta
knives case the requirements for a jury
are simple 18 people are needed 12
jurors and six alternates but finding an
impartial jury for that sub knife case
has been difficult and continues to
delay the trial according to tsarnaev's
defense sixty-eight percent of the
nearly 1400 people summoned to serve as
possible jurors have already come to a
verdict
and just as many say they have been
personally affected by the bombings
while the evidence against tsarnaev
appears to be overwhelming the US
criminal justice system is built on the
principle that an American is innocent
until proven guilty so surely judge
O'Toole has ensured that the jury
remains unbiased so that Dzhokhar
tsarnaev receives a fair trial not quite
he's rejected numerous requests from the
defense to move the trial to another
state but it's been done before remember
Timothy McVeigh in 1995 McVeigh was
charged with blowing up a federal
building in oklahoma city killing a
hundred and sixty-eight people the judge
in the case ordered that the venue be
moved to colorado stating that McVeigh
wouldn't be able to receive a fair trial
in Oklahoma and McVeigh was still found
guilty and sentenced to death so the
question with sapna ev's trial right now
is not about guilt or innocence but how
guilt or innocence is decided if the
process isn't fair how can some knife
sentencing be then there's the second
phase of the trial the sentencing if
convicted the 21 year old could face the
death penalty by the same jury
Massachusetts has banned the death
penalty but the US government has
authorized the death penalty in sub
knives case because it is a federal
terrorism case to ensure the possibility
of a death sentence prosecutors are
seeking a death qualified jury if that's
how scary that's because it is the
search for a death qualified jury means
that anyone who fundamentally opposed as
capital punishment is ruled out of
serving on the jury so who's left to
make up a jury of Dzhokhar tsarnaev's
peers then waltz have now get a fair
trial or will the quest for justice be
overtaken by the desire for vengeance
you